So DEC-POMDP, I've written out
the expansion of what it stands for.
Decentralized partially
observable Markov decision, and
then I kind of ran out of space.
>> Nah, the P doesn't matter.
>> But you know that it's a POMDP,
decentralized POMDP, and so
the quantities that define the DEC-POMDP
are very similar to the quantities that
define a POMDP,
we've got a set of states, transitions,
rewards, observations,
observation function.
The major difference is that
actions are actually taken
simultaneously by
a finite set of agents.
There isn't just one driver
there is actually a whole,
you know, too many emcees,
really, not enough mics.
>> Well done.
>> There's a set of agents who
actually get to have some say
over how the transitions works.
So we're going to say capital I
is that finite set of agents,
actions available to an agent
is A sub little i for agent I.
And the transition
function is a function of
the joint actions taken by all
the agents simultaneously.
So instead of just going from state
to a next state through an action,
this is actually, you could think of
it as a vector with one action for
each of the agents in our set.
>> All right.
That makes sense.
>> So that really is very
similar kind of quantity but
we break up where
the actions are happening.
They have to happen jointly.
And the agents themselves, their
observations about the environment,
are also distributed, in a sense.
Agent i gets to gets to see something
that's a function of the agent and
the state of the world.
All right, so, this is a model.
In this model,
all the agents are acting cooperatively,
because there's one shared reward
function that everybody gets.
If we actually split the reward
function so there's a different one for
each of the agents, we get yet
another model they're not
going to talk about caught up.
Partially observable stochastic game or
POSG.
>> POSG.
>> I'm positive that
would be interesting.
>> Yeah, yeah so we could POSG
this discussion at this point and
have a side discussion.
>> [LAUGH] More puns.
The P stands for puns.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, this makes sense and
sounds great as a formalism goes,
but I'm kind of struck.
When you brought up the stochastic games
thing, I was thinking the whole time,
this sounds like game theory stuff.
>> Yeah, yeah.
Right, it's sort of clearly game theory
when we have separate reward functions,
because every agent has its
own personal interests.
Right, so, the DEC-POMDP setup is
a kind of common interest game,
might be a word for it, the notion that
there's agents acting independently, but
they're all acting for the same reward.
>> So,
we could model this as game theory, or
is this some different
way of thinking about it?
>> It's part way between game theory and
POMDPs, yeah.
It has elements of both, and
in fact, I guess it subsumes both.
So, you can represent any POMDP as
a DEC-POMDP with just one agent.
And you can represent any common
interest game as a DEC-POMDP with
complete observability, or
maybe no states, that sort of thing.